en france une décision importante et
surtout très rare dans le domaine de la
justice la commission de révision de la
cour de cassation a en effet ordonné
aujourd'hui le réexamen du procès de
patrick dils
ce jeune homme a déjà passé 13 ans en
prison après avoir avoué le meurtre de
deux enfants
mais depuis l' enquête a permis de
prouver que le tueur en série francis
heaulme se trouvaient dans la région au
moment des faits patrick dils restera
tout de même en prison jusqu'au prochain
procès huguette hervé gutman oui un
nouveau procès noan libération la
commission de révision de la cour de
cassation a rendu une décision contraste
et les parents de patrick dils
incarcéré depuis 13 ans aurait
évidemment souhaité pouvoir l'embrasser
dès ce soir mais après tant de
déconvenues c'est déjà un premier pas
paris xiii en art et un mois et 15 jours
que nous apportons ça et on avait fait
confiance parce que fait des yeux
premiers soins
on pensait pas que ça on est bien un
très grand changement en ce jour de
septembre 86 deux enfants sont retrouvés
le long de la voie ferrée le crâne
fracassé à coups de pierres un peu plus
tard un adolescent de 16 ans est arrêté
très vite patrick dils à vous donne des
détails troublants puis se rétracte il
est condamné à la perpétuité
deux recours en cassation seront
rejetées et la présence de francis
heaulme le tueur en série sur les lieux
et le jour du drame change tout il
reconnaît que des enfants lui ont jeté
des pierres mais il nie toute
implication
statistiquement qu'elle ait la chance
qu'ils étaient sur le lieu du crime le
jour du crime alors du film qu'il ait vu
les victimes et il eut un mobile est
assassiné finirait pas fait c'est toute
la question se pose au juge de répondre
à cette question
en attendant patrick dils reste en
prison la présence de francis heaulme
est certes un fait nouveau a estimé la
commission mais il subsiste contre le
jeune homme une charge sérieuse la
question était de savoir est il opportun
de le remettre en liberté aujourd'hui
sachant qu'il devra comparaître détenu
puisque c'est une obligation du code
il doit se constituer prisonnier alors
peut-être c'est quelque chose qui a joué
en sa défaveur
ce qui est important c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la révision et été
prononcé la patience après tant d'années
passées en prison
patrick dils eux va devoir en faire
preuve avant que l'on reconnaisse
peut-être son innocence